hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series with the goal to
hanger-on people who've done a lot more
than us and hopefully by spending a
little more time with them some of their
mindset their values their beliefs their
habits will rub off onto us to help us
become the best version of ourselves
till today we're going to learn from
Steve Jobs on motivation mentor me Steve
a lot of people come to me they say well
I want to be an entrepreneur and I go
that's great what's your idea and they
go well I don't have one yet and I say
well I think you should go get a job as
a busboy or something until you find
something you're really passionate about
because it's a lot of work and I'm
convinced that about half of what
separates the successful entrepreneurs
from the non successful ones is pure
perseverance it is so hard you pour so
much your life into this thing there are
such rough moments in time that most
people give up I don't blame them it's
really tough and it consumes your life I
mean if you're if you've got a family
and you're in the early days of a
company it's I can't imagine how one
could do it I'm sure it's it's been done
but it's rough for me because it's a
pretty much you know at 18 hour day job
seven days a week for a while so unless
you have a lot of passion about this
you're going to not survive you're going
to give it up so you got to have an idea
of or a problem or a wrong that you want
to write that you're passionate about
otherwise you're not going to have the
perseverance to stick it through and I
think that's half the battle right there
it's hard to remember how bad it was you
know in 1980s with IBM taking over the
world with the PC with Doss out there it
was it was far worse than the Apple -
they tried to copy the Apple - and they
done a pretty bad job and you needed to
know a lot and so things were kind of
slipping backwards and Macintosh was you
saw the 1984 commercial you know put
that I hope you have that in your
archives
you know Macintosh was basically this
this relatively small company you know
in Cupertino California taking on the
Goliath IBM and saying wait a minute
your way is wrong this is not the way we
want computer
to go this is not the legacy we want to
leave this is not what we want our kids
to be learning this is wrong and we are
going to show you the right way to do it
and here it is it's called Macintosh and
this is so much better that it's going
to beat you and we are going to do it
and that's what Apple stood for yeah mr.
jobs you're a bright man here it comes
bad and clear that on several counts
you've discussed you don't know what
you're talking about
I would like for example for you to
express in clear terms how say Java in
any of its incarnations addresses the
ideas embodied and opened up and when
you're finished with that perhaps you
could tell us what you personally have
been doing for the last seven years
ah
you know you can please some of the
people some of the time but
one of the hardest things when you're
trying to affect change is that people
like this gentleman are right in some
areas I'm sure that there are some
things opendoc does probably even more
than I'm not familiar with that nothing
else out there does and I'm sure that
you can make some demos maybe a small
commercial app that demonstrates those
things the hardest thing is what how
does that fit in to a cohesive larger
vision that's going to allow you to sell
eight billion dollars 10 billion dollars
a product a year and one of the things
I've always found is that you've got to
start with the customer experience and
work backwards to the technology you
can't start with the technology and try
to figure out where you're going to try
to sell it and I've made this mistake
probably more than anybody else in this
room and I got the scar tissue to prove
it and I know that it's the case and as
we have tried to come up with a strategy
and a vision for Apple it started with
what incredible benefits can we give to
the customer where can we take the
customer not not starting with let's sit
down with the engineers and and figure
out what awesome technology we have and
then how are we going to market that and
I think that's the right path to take I
remember with the laser writer we built
the world's first small laser printer as
you know and there was awesome
technology in that box we have the first
canon laser printing cheap laser
printing engine in the world in the
United States here at Apple we had a
very wonderful printer controller that
we
line we had Adobe's PostScript software
in there we had Apple talk in there just
awesome technology in the box and I
remember seeing the first printout come
out of it and just picking it up and
looking at anything you know we can sell
this because you don't have to know
anything about what's in that box
all we have to do is hold the some good
you want this and if you remember back
to 1984 before laser printers
it was pretty startling to see that
people went wow yes and that's that's
where Apple's got to get back to and you
know I'm sorry that opened docks a
casualty along the way and I readily
admit there are many things in life that
I don't the faintest idea what I'm
talking about so I apologize for that
too but there's a whole lot of people
working super super hard right now at
Apple you know avi John Marino Fred I
mean the whole team is working burning
the midnight oil trying to and people
you know hundreds of people below them
to execute on some of these things and
they're doing the best and I think that
what we need to do and some mistakes
will be made by the way some mistakes
will be made along the way that's good
because at least some decisions are
being made along the way and we'll find
the mistakes we'll fix them and I think
what we need to do is support that team
going through this very important stage
as they work their butts off they're all
getting calls being offered three times
as much money to go do this that the
valley's hot none of them are leaving
and I think we need to support them and
see them through this and write some
damn good applications to support Apple
out in the market that's my own point of
view mistakes we made some people will
be pissed off some people will not know
what they're talking about but it's I
think it is so much better than where
things were not very long ago and I
think we're going to get there
I think the Macintosh was created by a
group of people who felt that there
wasn't a strict division between sort of
science and
art or in other words that mathematics
is really a liberal art if you look at
it from a slightly different point of
view and why can't we interject
typography into computers why can't we
have computers talking to us in English
language and looking back five years
later this seems like a trivial
observation but at the time it was
cataclysmic and its consequences and the
battles that were fought to push this
point of view out the door were very
large was focused mostly was was the
brilliant hardware engineer and focused
on the core design of the computer and I
was worrying about which parts we ought
to use and how we were going to build
these things and how it sort of somebody
that wasn't the Oise was going to manage
to buy all the extra parts he still
needed to buy and plug this thing
together because you still needed to buy
your own keyboard your own display in
your own power supply and so you needed
to be pretty much of a hardware hobbyist
now we made the very important decision
was to not offer our computers a kit
even though you needed to buy these
extra parts that the main computer board
itself came fully assembled we were the
first company in the world to do that
everybody else was offering their little
computers a kit and what that meant was
was there was maybe an order of
magnitude more people who could actually
buy our computer and use it than if they
had to build it themselves and the Apple
2 was actually the first computer to
come fully assembled where you didn't
have to do anything and the reason there
was it was our observation that for
every hardware hobbyist someone who
could either build the kit themselves or
at least find these five or ten extra
parts that needed there were a thousand
potential software hobbyists and if they
didn't have to do anything with the
hardware except use it ran at that time
and that meant write their own programs
still there was a much larger group of
people that could take advantage of this
so we wanted to reach them and that was
the the real breakthrough in the Apple
to my entire life's been spent only in
one industry which is this one and but
I've been in it now for about 15 years
and I've seen a lot of people make a lot
of things I've seen a lot of people fail
a lot of things and my my point of view
on this or my observation is that the
doers are the major thinkers
the people that really create the things
that change this industry are both the
thinker doer in one person and if we
really go back and we examine you know
did Leonardo have a guy off to the side
that was thinking five years out in the
future what he would paint or the
technology he would use the paint and of
course not Leonardo was the artist but
he also mixed all his own paints he also
was a fairly good chemist knew about
pigments knew about human anatomy and
combining all of those skills together
the art and the science the thinking and
the doing was what resulted in the
exceptional result and there is no
difference in our industry the people
that really made the contributions have
been the thinkers and the doers and when
you when you a lot of people of course
it's very easy to take credit for the
thinking the doing is more concrete but
somebody is very easy for somebody say
oh I thought of this three years ago but
usually when you dig a little deeper you
find that the people that really did it
we're also the people that really work
through the hard intellectual problems
as well our customers want to know who
is Apple and what is it that we stand
for
where do we fit in this world and what
we're about isn't making boxes for
people to get their jobs done although
we do that well we do that better than
almost anybody in some cases
but apples about something more than
that Apple at the core its core value is
that we believe that people with passion
can change the world for the better
that's what we believe and we've had the
opportunity to work with people like
that we've had an opportunity work with
people like you with software developers
with customers who have done it in some
big and some small ways and we believe
that in this world people can change it
for the better and that those people
that are crazy enough to think they can
change the world are the ones that
actually do and so what we're going to
do in our first brand marketing campaign
in several years is to is to get back to
that core value a lot of things have
changed the markets a totally different
place than it was a decade ago and
apples totally different in apples
placing it is totally different and
believe me the products and the
distribution strategy of manufacturing a
totally different we understand that but
values and core values those things
shouldn't change the things that Apple
believed in at its core are the same
things that Apple really stands for
today and so we wanted to find a way to
communicate this and what we have is
something that I am I'm very moved by it
honors those people who have changed the
world some of them are living some of
them are not but the ones that aren't as
you'll see you know that if they ever
use the computer it would have been a
Mac
the theme of the campaign is is think
difference is the people honoring the
people who think different and who move
this world forward and it's it is what
we are about it touches the soul of this
company so I'm gonna go ahead and roll
it and I hope that you feel the same way
about it I do here's to the crazy ones
The Misfits the rebels frenemies eggs
and smiles ones who see things
differently they're not fond of rules
and they have no respect for the status
quo you can quote them disagree with
them glorify or vilify them now the only
thing you can't do is ignore them
because they change things they push the
human race forward and suddenly seem as
the crazy ones we see genius
as the people who are crazy enough to
think they can change the world are the
ones who do when this whole thing with
Gizmodo happened I got a lot of advice
from people that said you've got to just
let it slide you can't uh you shouldn't
you shouldn't go after a journalist
because they bought stolen property and
they tried to extort you should let it
slide Apple's a big company now you
don't want the PR you should let it
slide and I thought deeply about this
and I ended up concluding that the worst
thing that could possibly happen as we
get big and we get a little more
influence in the world is if we change
our core values and start letting it
slide I can't do that I'd rather quit
you know you go back five years ago what
would we have done if something like
this happened you go back ten years ago
you know what would you do if without
going into that it we had the same
values now as we had then we're maybe a
little more experienced certainly more
beat up but but the core values are the
same and we come into work wanting to do
the same thing today as as we did five
or ten years ago which is build the best
products for people you know there's
nothing that makes my day more than
getting an email from some random person
in the universe who just bought an iPad
over in the UK and tells me the story
about how it's the coolest product
they've ever brought home you know in
their lives that's what keeps me going
and it's what kept me going five years
ago it's what kept me going ten years
ago when
the doors were almost closed and it's
what will keep me going five years from
now whatever happens so I don't see why
you have to change if you get big we
went through that stage and Apple where
we went out and we thought oh we're
going to be a big company let's hire
professional management we went out and
hired a bunch of professional management
it didn't work at all most of them were
bozos they knew how to manage but they
didn't know how to do anything and so
what if you're a great person why do you
want to work for somebody you can't
learn anything from and you know what's
interesting you know the best managers
are there are the great individual
contributors who never ever want to be a
manager but decide they have to be a
manager because every no one else is
going to be able to do as good a job as
them we wanted people that were insanely
great at what they did but work we're
not necessarily those seasoned
professionals but who has on at the tips
of their fingers and in their passion
the latest understanding of where
technology was and what we could do with
that technology and who wanted to bring
that to lots of people so the neatest
thing that happens is when you get a
core group of you know ten great people
they it becomes self-policing as to who
they led into that group so I consider
the most important job of someone like
myself is recruiting the best way I came
up with to affect change at Apple was by
example and that was probably more than
anything else the key reason that I
spent two and a half years of my life on
Macintosh was to try by example to say
hey here's a better way to do things and
it turns out it's worth I mean almost
everything at Apple now has looked at
the Macintosh experience and come in and
said hey we can take a lot of these
concepts and apply them make them better
in some ways and model in every other
Factory we're doing now is modeled after
the Macintosh Factory every other
product team that's doing new product is
being modeled after the Macintosh team
with a group of people that do not use
quality in their marketing are the
Japanese you never see them using
quality in their marketing it's only the
American companies that do and yet if
you ask people on the street which
products have the best reputation for
quality they will tell you the Japanese
now why is that how could that be the
answer is because customers don't form
their opinions on quality from marketing
they don't form their opinions on
quality from who won the the Deming
award or who won the Baldrige award they
form their opinions on quality from
their own experience with the products
or the services and so one can spend
enormous amounts of money on quality one
can win every quality where there is and
yet if your products don't live up to it
customers will not keep that opinion for
long in their minds and so I think where
we have to start is with our products
and our services not with our marketing
department and we need to get back to
the basics and go improve our products
and services
now again quality isn't just the product
or the service it's having the right
product you know knowing where the
markets going and having the most
innovative products is just as much a
part of quality as the quality of the
construction of the product when you
have it and I think what we're seeing is
the quality leaders of today have
integrated that quality technology well
beyond their manufacturing now going
well into their sales and marketing and
out as far as they can to touch the
customer and trying to create super
efficient processes back from the
customer all the way through to the
delivery of the end product so that they
can have the most innovative products
understand the customer needs fastest
etc etc when Bill and I first met each
other and work together in the early
days generally we were both the youngest
guys in the room right individually or
together I'm about six months older than
he is but roughly the same age and now
when we're working at our respective
companies I know about you but I'm the
oldest guy in the room most of the time
and that's why I love being here
so happy to oblige happy to oblige and
uh you know I think of I think of most
things in life as either a Bob Dylan or
a Beatles song but there's that that one
line and that one Beatle song you and I
have memories longer than the road that
stretches out ahead and that's that's
clearly true here and well you know what
I think we should end it there let's
just end it there I'm a little tear
right here thank you thank you very much
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what you thought of the
video I'd love to know which clip
resonated most with you and why and what
change or realization you're going to
make as a result of watching this video
leaving the comments below and I will
join in the discussion I also wanted to
give a quick shout out to cool deep from
quick times app calm cool deep thank you
so much for buying a copy of my book it
means a lot to me for your chains at a
shadow in a future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your seat so we can keep track thank you
so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon